with every jab we move
closer to hitting one of the most
ambitious targets set for this country
to vaccinate all uk adults by the end of
july
we are now halfway there fifty percent
of our adult population
have been given their first dose it's
not my birthday until next month i
wasn't expecting it till at least past
then
so it's at least a month ahead of what i
was expecting so yeah it's been
absolutely brilliant
monumental achievement would not have
been possible without the efforts
of an army of healthcare workers and
volunteers
people like dr kimberling and his
colleagues
at this practice in york i think it is a
success story it's
um it's a continuing work we're not
finished yet
50 isn't where we're aiming for i'm glad
i'm really pleased that we've met that
landmark
and i'm also really pleased that we're
challenged to keep going and
and keep on with second doses for people
as well
we are now just five million short of
the second key target
vaccinating the first nine priority
groups
by the 15th of april and at this rate
that targets will be met ahead of
schedule
the vaccination program is our route out
of the pandemic
it will help us to protect people and we
know that these vaccines
protect you but we also know that they
protect
those around you and they make it less
likely
that others your loved ones will catch
coronavirus too
and of course for all of us they're our
root out so
i'm just delighted that so many people
are coming forward and getting the jab
the success of this vaccination rollout
has raised hopes of a return to
post-lock down normality
including summer holidays abroad
but rising covered cases across the
continent
mean restriction-free travel to europe
remains
unlikely well i think booking a
holiday abroad there's a reasonable
chance that it
it may not go ahead um certainly
the increase in covida
across europe makes
it unlikely that for some countries in
europe
uh we're likely to be able to travel
there anytime soon i think the european
countries being a little bit behind in
terms of vaccination doesn't really help
with those travel plans
uh it certainly pushes them back a bit
and it's this
travel uncertainty that's worrying
thousands of britons desperate to
finalize their summer plans
at the moment we have a holiday booked
for may
and we're really not sure whether we
will be going or not
based on um guidelines so will i need a
vaccine
because of my age i won't get a vaccine
yet or
will international travel just require a
negative test
we've not been told we don't know when
we'll be told so it's
it's all up in the air really so i said
yeah your angle floppy just completely
less relaxed
the global pandemic has shown just how
interconnected our world
really is now we need our european
neighbors
vaccine programs to become more
effective for us
all to begin to move out of this crisis
ashish joshi skynews